guten Tag Christop und guten Tag Marti
ich habe zwei Fragen an dich und zwar
die eine lautet also die zwei Fragen
sind ziemlich klein deswegen könnte man
sie auch als eine formulieren aber ich
fange jetzt einfach mal an die erste
Frage lautet mit wie viel Jahren hast du
deinen ersten Promi bzw daar
imittiert und die zweite Frage lautet
welchen promy ja welchen prom hast du
imitiert
lieber mit dem fing welchen Promi hast
du
imitiert als erstes imitiert und mit wie
viel Jahren war das das W meine zwei
Fragen gewesen und ich würde mich über
eine Antwort
freuen ja youtube hat mal wieder
irgendwie das Video am Ende
abgeschnitten gut das kennen wir ja
nun mit wie viel Jahren ich weiß es gar
nicht so richtig das muss irgendwie mit
mit 12 gewesen sein und das war äh ja
der Wochenshow Mensch bastian Pastewka
in seiner Rolle als OTM Zittlau und
vielleicht ich weiß nicht ob man den
noch kennt also die Generation die nach
mir kommt jetzt die kenne ih glaube ich
nicht mehr der war so ein bisschen ja
hallo ne ich singe priat ja auch mal
sehr gerne ne ha und ja so
lich